more than 2 million Americans are
estimated to be servers in this country
those big numbers can lead to congestion
at some surf spots so many surfers have
decided that riding the waves can also
happen at night Carter Evans is in
Malibu he zipped up as wetsuit to find
out how some are getting well you could
say moonstruck it's Twilight over the
Malibu coastline and while most Sun
seekers are winding down their day this
craft is just getting started
[Music]
not surfing is awesome because you can
cruise all night long it's like dancing
on the water you're not going by sight
you're going by field
it's not for the faint of heart or the
short sighting coming for a sport that
depends on seeing the right wave at the
perfect time it may seem crazy to dive
into darkness but as I found out on my
first night surf session it's all about
escaping the crowds if it were light out
here there'd be a hundred guys out three
hundred guys and everybody running into
each other but here it's like we had the
whole place to ourselves
yeah right now there's like hardly
anybody out hell mood I goal is one of
the estimated 35 million surfers around
the world as those numbers grow so do
the few Daredevils drawn by the light of
the full moon you're watching the light
off the wave and you can see it's kind
of like a serpent on the water so you're
kind of following it as you go along go
anything go but while they're avoiding
surf line gridlock they're risking
encounters with other underwater
creatures some known to be more active
at night there have been a tremendous
number of shark sightings down south
this year do you think about that at all
at night nice true at night you do at
night right a longboard because I like
to keep my feet up and out of the water
sometime at night though you're not
gonna see it coming no it's night head
for the fun maybe that's the whole thing
I don't want to see it coming
yeah night surfing isn't new experts say
wetsuit warriors have been quietly doing
it for decades but in 2011 the sport got
a social media boost from this
off the North Shore of Maui Australian
pro surfer Marc Visser conquered one of
the world's fiercest waves nicknamed
jaws at night my eyeballs were just
pulsing my heart was pounding so much
and I was just telling myself you know
just stay on your feet to stay on your
feet it was one of the scariest things
but the most exciting thing at the same
time this was ride on this 30-foot
monster took four years of preparation a
small army of support staff and three
specially built surfboards so the lights
are not for you the lights are so the
safety people can see you yes see where
I'm going it made it look like a bit of
a fast and furious kind of car that look
is now catching on Roy Johnson used
tonight surf as younger man now he
spends his free time crafting boards
with LED lights built into them I like
the reactions of the crowd because I'll
be sitting there watching my son out
there surfing and some people just come
up and are like what is that it's so
cool
so you're the official product tester
absolutely
so Rena shine sharks are not we're out
there all right
Roy's son Sean says while the LEDs
signal his position to other surfers for
safety
mostly they make an impression back on
shore what do people say when you're out
in the water they're tripping yeah I
mean they're thinking it to UFO come
down with
it's like a painting out there you could
paint whatever you want to do up there
you know just draw it all over the fish
no it tastes the way of yeah but at the
end of the day or night surfing is more
sport than our and some prefer to keep
it old-school I feel like I'm at
Halloween or something makes it kind of
interesting it's a little bit disco but
I think I'll just stick with my glow
stick and the moon if it's out and once
each month weather permitting that's the
one beacon every can agree on if it's a
full moon and it's clear I can go for it
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Malibu
this is one of those instances where we
say proudly only on CBS yeah that's
right beautiful beautiful editing yeah
like a dog told Kristen or when you were
in here Charlie shared with us Jeff boy
was sitting in your chair he said that
he water skis at night and Jeff course
ed he would do a story on it and Charlie
said yes what I do it I'm in yeah
wouldn't you want to see that yeah she
wants to participate in that hi dear
home I'll be on the shore Lou that's
another Oh looks a bit like it look
there I mean when there was a full moon
yeah yeah Sue Ann I'd love to see that
awesome
all right that's a TIA yeah